hi guys and welcome to a tutorial on
detailed building today in this tutorial
I won't show you how to build anything
but rather i will show you a way to
learn stuff and build things in rolla
cosas country in your own way because i
want to move away from actually teaching
people how to do certain things and
because the best way to improve if
you're already experienced at the game
is to learn something new to learn a new
way I guess of building things and
that's essentially something I want to
show today and it's something that since
I've learned about this I was able to
learn things myself without having
people to tell me what things I should
do now the first thing I would like to
show today is this building over here
which you can if you have some
experience in the game you can clearly
tell that this is mostly made out of
Ralphie's medieval sets and there is the
arch in the middle over there which is
from my own set which is still
unreleased and I'm sorry about that
other than that there is not really too
much going on you can practically
recreate this building with one set now
this does not mean that this is a bad
building I think this is a pretty good
building and if you're using it that's
fine if you're building something like
this it'll probably look good and I must
say there is some detail on this
building and it has a nice shape and
it'll probably work well for whatever
you want to suit it for but another
building that I would like to show which
is practically the same is this building
over here now I'm fairly certain that
tastes of course do differ but then
again i'm pretty sure that most people
were actually agree that this is the
best building out of the two now if you
pay close attention to this building
you'll see that i haven't really added
too much from Ralphie's medieval world
but rather from all kinds of other sets
and that the pieces are used in a sense
that they are not even really supposed
to be used in the thing is a building
automatically is going to look better if
you don't recognize anything in it
because seeing these same kind of
buildings over and over again seeing
people use shy guys alpine village and
even though the buildings that people
may create with that said are different
in size and shape you can recognize the
same pieces and
even if somebody creates an entirely new
building using those pieces it will be
something that you've seen before and it
won't make too much of an impact on you
while this with at least I hope pieces
that are not really commonly used in
this kind of sense it makes the anti
structure look a lot more interesting
and the way that I like to go about
doing this is stone off with a structure
like you do like you just saw it is
definitely not a problem to just start
off with something like this because
that's how I did build the second
building after all and then just go into
sets and something this can just be such
that you've never opened before that you
just downloaded or that you have no idea
of what they're actually supposed to do
and just run through them and see if
there are pieces that you can use now if
you look at this building you may
recognize a couple of pieces for example
this small balcony thing over here is
from either Ralphie's Arabian days or
Arabian Nights I don't really remember
anymore but I've never really seen
somebody use it on a medieval tower now
of course this may have been done but
when I tried it on this building it just
turned out that it worked perfectly and
I had that nice little balcony thing
going and it looks interesting and it's
refreshing to see you really have to go
through various sets and look at pieces
and only every five or ten minutes do
you find something that is truly useful
and that you can truly add on to your
building but from that moment onward
you'll recognize that that object is
something that you can use in that kind
of case for example I was incredibly
lost trying to get this gone and bore in
the middle because that's something that
buildings in real life often have but I
never really found out which said it was
in even though I knew this ad so I asked
people and I wanna shout out to max
because he told me that it was a clear
main street set 5 and from that moment
onward I knew that there was a golden
boy in main street set 5 and I knew I
would be able to use it in ways like
this but it's an object that you
remember and because of the fact that
you keep remembering objects the kind of
process of going through sets and
experimenting with them is going to go
quicker the more you do it so I guess
that's a bit of an um motivation for
people just out there
who want to start doing this and I've
never really done it before now if you
look at this tower it is quite complex
because this thing at the top is from
pets efteling set the square pole in the
middle is from mobis glass and
frameworks this little thing which i
have no idea what it actually is it's
from Ralphie's asian sent the Golem boat
is from Main Street 5 this thing is from
pat's efteling set this is from
Ralphie's medieval this weird I have no
idea what that even is is from boy blue
I think that's the name of the set and
this thing is from station James castle
things too and in fact this tower is
made up of two different towers from
Ralphie's medieval because it uses the
towel from the first set as well as the
towel from the second set which somehow
magically actually worked very well
together so I started to add that and if
you look at this little door Mary kind
of thing it is actually made up of two
pieces from arabian nights and or
Iranian days I still don't know which is
which but that actually worked very well
too because this stucco area and this
golden kind of support structure were
two separate items that actually worked
really well together and just by going
through sets and experimenting with
things and using as many different sets
as you can with in one building as long
as it looks good is definitely going
it's definitely something that is going
to make your bill makes look great or
another building that I wanted to look
at is a building that I've recently
created and this is a estonian orthodox
cathedral very inspired by a building
and selling and it's a really awesome
building and you know this is a theme
which is rarely even try to especially
if you're using a theme that has rarely
been done before it's going to be really
easy or almost necessary to experiment
with things so that's a nice way to get
that going but as you can see also this
building it's got some interesting
things going on in it and even though
there is a lot of Ralphie's antique
world you can also see that there are
many sets you spin in this one building
the golden arches over here are from
cocoa notice European Main Street the
small round arch is from my forum
romanum set these side stone things not
really sure what they are from a treat
one while these bottom little why
areas are from shy guys Main Street 9
and etc etc many pieces of this building
are from various different sets and one
thing I actually really like about this
building is the roofs it took me a very
long time to find which roofs I should
use and yes those things totally look
like Hershey's Kisses somebody taught me
and I can't unsee it anymore but I was
looking for a Russian Orthodox roof and
if you know roller coaster in three
community nobody builds Russian
buildings well rarely anybody and so
there weren't really any consumers ed
sets for what I needed in this case and
after a long time of experimenting with
various things and realizing that there
was no such thing I eventually ended up
somehow opening my own Alpine set and it
turned out that my church spires were
actually very well fit for the top of a
Russian Orthodox kind of architecture
Cathedral so that was a very surprising
moment and this is a very good example
of how an object if taken away from its
own context and placed in a different
context can actually give a much
different look and actually look a lot
better in some cases now the last
building i wanted to show today was this
baltic building yes it's another baltic
building you may notice that it uses a
lot of coconut as European Main Street
set which is a pretty unknown sent I
really recommend it it's an awesome set
but it also uses a lot of shy guys oh
those the tower it also uses a lot of
shy guys main street as you can see
there is Main Street set number nine in
these cornices but there is also
Ralphie's antique world in this freeze
and if we look over here we find the
walls the bottom walls from Ralphie's
antique world as well as the main street
number nine bottom cornices and this
small support kind of fence thingies are
actually made up of shy guys not Main
Street number nine supports with the
caps from Moby steel jungle and some
random decoration thing from shy guys
Main Street one and this balcony was
from some random German Roman said I
think and it's just such a mix of random
shots that just turned out to work in a
coherent way and when placed in the same
context the
objects that are actually meant for
different things can actually turn into
the thing that you want them to be
turned into as long as the context
states that they are that certain thing
because Moby still jungle caps would in
no other scenario look like something
that you would have on top of fence
posts but because it does have the kind
of neoclassical actually this is a very
Art Nouveau kind of building it does
look like that and that's what I'm
trying to tell is that you should
experiment with many sets just try the
pieces and use them for things that they
are not supposed to be used for because
that is what really going to make your
buildings look great if you are just
starting out or you don't have much
experience you can get better by copying
people and looking at tutorials and
trying to do what they are doing but if
you really want to take the next step
you're gonna have to come up with ideas
on your own and this is why this
tutorial is so much different from any
other tutorial I've made because I need
to tell you guys that I can't help you
with this you're on your own with this
now I can give you some ideas and
explain how this all works but honestly
it is all down to you and just get some
sets just work on buildings and go
through sets that are not even supposed
to be used for the theme and see if
there's anything in there that you can
use and if it is then remember that and
remember it for future reference and in
that way you can even build up your own
style and come up with things on your
own and I definitely haven't learned and
everything that's out there there are
people out there that are better than me
and more experienced in many ways and
for anybody in the community however the
learning is never over there are always
days when you can learn something new or
days when somebody else comes out with a
new custom scenery set and there are
thousands of users you can have within
one custom seen reset and not just the
things that the Creator says you have to
do with it and that's one last message
that I were to end this video with and
I'm sorry if this video was too
different than usual stuff I'll try to
get back to that but this is really
something I wanted to tell you guys
because I think it's very important to
take this different look
building in rolla cosecant three